in the opening scene we see a man who
appears to be an office worker he wakes
up and discovers that he is locked
inside a vault room which contains
nothing but a padlocked metal cupboard a
lifeless rat and a fluorescent lamp
filled with dead flies the man gets up
on his feet and attempts to open the
vault door but his efforts are in vain
at first he suspects that his colleagues
are trying to pull a prank on him so he
searches around for hidden cameras but
finds none a few hours pass by and
there's still no activity from Beyond
the vault door this causes the unnamed
man to become more puzzled as to what is
going on a short while later he begins
to get desperate and pounds on the door
expressing an urgent need to use the
bathroom but his voice goes unanswered
he tries calling for help using his cell
phone but there is no network inside the
Vault his attempts to break open the
metal cupboard also prove
frustration mounts leading him to
verbally lash out at his colleague
claiming that he will fire him once he
gets out of it following this the man
resorts to using his belt to make noise
against the door in hopes that someone
will hear the sound but again to no
avail in an act of defiance he urinates
inside the Vault believing that he is
humiliating those pranksters who are
behind all of this however there is
still no response and now he's just
standing in his own piss as the hours
pass exhaustion sets in and the man
becomes weaker due to the absence of
food and water it is the second day the
man for one more time checks his cell
phone for a Network signal but there is
no change to make matters worse he
accidentally drops his phone while
stuffing it into his pocket causing it
to break at this point he becomes so
thirsty that he decides to do something
drastic he urinates in his leather shoe
and drinks it considering it worse than
a light beer after this the man begins
kicking and punching his surroundings in
the midst of his Outburst he strikes the
fluorescent lamp above him and
unexpectedly notices a key inside it
seizing the opportunity he pull down the
light and retrieves the key which
enables him to open the metal covered
inside he discovers a collection of
tools notably a blowtorch a wrench a
hammer and a chisel utilizing these
items the man decides to cut through the
vault door however his lack of knowledge
on how to operate the tool leads him to
give up after a few minutes leaving only
a scorched mark on the vault's iron door
following this the man attempts to
trigger the fire alarm in the ceiling
and activate the sprinklers he is
hopeful that he can extract drinkable
water from it but to his disappointment
the alarm is of no use as even after
torching it with fire nothing happened
this only intensifies his frustration
prompting him to vent his anger on the
metal cupboard by knocking it down
however he soon manages to calm himself
down realizing that he has to save his
energy as much as possible because there
is nothing to eat he reassures himself
that he is not insane not dreaming and
is still alive a few moments later the
man notices a small hole in one of the
walls located behind the metal cupboard
with renewed hope he uses the hammer and
chisel to chip away at the wall and
create an opening as he starts breaking
through the walls the oxygen level
within the Vault room begins to lower as
a result he proceeds to inhale the
oxygen from the cylinder he had
discovered earlier unfortunately the
concentration of oxygen proves to be too
high causing him to feel light-headed he
then closes the valve to balance the
oxygen like before at this point the man
becomes extremely fragile due to hunger
hence he sets his sights on a deceased
mouse that has become a feeding ground
for maggots he then reluctantly consumes
the maggots leaving the dead rat for
later in the next scene the man
continues his excavation and finally
makes a breakthrough he comes across the
steel bars which he cuts using the
blowtorch before long a ray of light
penetrates through the hole giving him
renewed hope once again the man then
increases his pace and gradually makes
the hole big enough to pass himself
through it however when he reaches the
other side he becomes distressed to
learn that even this room is another
Vault just like the one he was
previously trapped in this infuriates
him a lot because all of his efforts
have gone in vain unlike the first Vault
the second room contains a coffin and a
lamp adjacent to it filled with
curiosity he opens the lid of the coffin
only to find a woman dressed in
traditional attire peacefully sleeping
inside cautiously he touches the woman
to check if she is dead but much to his
shock she wakes up startled by his
presence in the sight of the Chisel in
his hand she screams in horror and
hastily runs away from him despite his
attempts to communicate they find
themselves unable to understand each
other due to the language barrier
overwhelmed with fear the woman escapes
to the first Vault room where the man
had been staying the latter doesn't try
to chase her and instead he simply lies
down in the coffin to take rest on the
third day the woman wakes the man up and
urges him to continue digging the tunnel
however the poor guy has no energy left
to work any further his hands have also
become badly injured due to the
Relentless labor with no options left
the man proceeds to teach the woman how
to dig the tunnel and she innocently
Begins the task while they are working
the woman realizes she needs to relieve
herself and heads to the other room for
some privacy the man follows her and
intervenes just as she is about to
remove her pants through gestures and
sign language He suggests that she
urinate in his leather shoes so that
they can use it as a source of water ah
thank God he figured out a way to not be
creepy initially hesitant she eventually
agrees to do so upon learning that the
man has been without water for three
days and her urine is important for his
survival they then proceed with this
weird solution and the man drinks the
urine without much thought he also
offers the woman to drink some and
although disgusted she reluctantly does
so after this the man consumes some more
maggots gaining the protein he was
lacking he then resumes his digging work
while the woman sits in a corner
overcome with sorrow for her unfortunate
fate she murmurs in her own language
expressing her disappointment that she
was meant to attend a wedding that day
and was filled with excitement for the
same however now that she finds herself
trapped all her Joy has disappeared she
cries questioning what she did wrong to
end up in such a dire situation
witnessing her distressed the man
decides to lift her Spirits by singing a
song it's called the I drank your shoe
pee song with his encouragement the
woman slowly wipes away her tears and
joins him in singing however their
fleeting moment of happiness is
short-lived as the man accidentally hits
his own hand instead of the Chisel
causing him to bleed as a result the
woman removes her headscarf tears it
into strips and uses it to bandage his
wound following this the two Begin work
in cooperation focusing on digging
through the wall as they continue on
with their work the lock on the vault
door behind them starts rotating
automatically seeing this they
immediately Rush towards the door in an
attempt to open it but as they approach
the door it becomes becomes locked this
recurring pattern continues and they
consider ignoring it assuming that
someone is toying with them but after a
while they finally decipher the actual
trick on how to open the door turns out
that as long as they have their backs
turned to the vault door it unlocks on
its own with this Revelation The Man
devises A Plan and the duo cautiously
walks backwards towards it surprisingly
the door remains open and the two are
able to access the third room but just
like the previous instance they find
themselves in yet another vaults but
this time it has an empty grave with a
tombstone placed at its Center upon
looking around the room the woman
suggests using the same trick of turning
their backs on the vault door to open it
the man likes the idea and so they
position themselves with their backs
towards the door and start digging the
grave further unfortunately their
strategy fails to yield the desired
outcome This Time by this point the man
is overcome with exhaustion due to
prolonged hunger and dehydration he
gradually loses hope and lays down in
the grave worried the woman checks on
him and realizes that he has a fever due
to his weakened state after a while the
man begins to think that the Mastermind
behind of this wants them to turn
against each other he guesses that they
will not be able to escape unless one of
them is killed and that the grave in
that room symbolizes the fate of one of
them as tensions escalate the man
contemplates killing the woman but he
lacks the courage to carry out such an
act he cries out expressing his
desperation and stating that he can
endure consuming dead rats and maggots
but cannot bring himself to take
someone's life by this moment the man
has lost all hope and he simply wants to
pass away peacefully however the woman
slaps and kicks him urging him to stay
awake she then somehow manages to carry
him out of the grave and allows him to
rest for a while an hour later the
enraged woman starts screaming and
banging on the Vault doors she directs
her cries towards God questioning why
she has been trapped and what sin she
has committed overwhelmed by emotions
she breaks down in tears even in this
critical moment she feeds her tears to
the man as a means of sustaining his
life shortly after she holds his hand
and unexpectedly kisses him she then
undresses the man and starts touching
him gently which quickly wakes him up
the plan is keep him Alive by having
coitus with him and even if it fails at
least he'll be stoked surprisingly the
plan works and the man gets rejuvenated
after the ordeal the two then decide to
rest for a few hours in the next scene
the man wakes up and finds the woman
curled up beside him sensing her
discomfort from the cold he crawls into
the second room cares The Velvet lining
from the coffin and returns to cover her
with it extremely exhausted the man
collapses once again onto the ground a
few hours later the man hears the vault
door unlocking itself similar to before
hastily he awakens the woman but
prevents her from looking at the door
the two then employ their previous trick
and somehow manage to walk backward
making their way towards the iron door
as soon as they step outside of the room
they are filled with immense relief as
they are greeted by a breathtaking
scenery featuring waterfalls birds and
flowers witnessing The Paradise in front
of them the two smile at each other and
the movie comes to an end subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for